The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer
high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
OK, so remember,
we've seen Stokes theorem,
which says if I have a closed
curve bounding some surface,
S,
and I orient the curve and the
surface compatible with each
other,
then I can compute the line
integral along C along my curve
in terms of,
instead,
surface integral for flux of a
different vector field,
namely, curl f dot n dS.
OK, so that's the statement.
And, just to clarify a little
bit, so, again,
we've seen various kinds of
integrals.
So, line integrals we know how
to evaluate.
They take place in a curve.
You express everything in terms
of one variable,
and after substituting,
you end up with a usual one
variable integral that you know
how to evaluate.
And, surface integrals,
we know also how to evaluate.
Namely, we've seen various
formulas for ndS.
Once you have such a formula,
due to the dot product with
this vector field,
which is not the same as that
one.
But it's a new vector field
that you can build out of f.
You do the dot product.
You express everything in terms
of your two integration
variables, and then you
evaluate.
So, now, what does this have to
do with various other things?
So, one thing I want to say has
to do with how Stokes helps us
understand path independence,
so, how it actually motivates
our criterion for gradient
fields,
independence.
OK, so,
we've seen that if we have a
vector field defined in a simply
connected region,
and its curl is zero,
then it's a gradient field,
and the line integral is path
independent.
So, let me first define for you
when a simply connected region
is.
So, we say that a region in
space is simply connected -- --
if every closed loop inside this
region bounds some surface again
inside this region.
OK, so let me just give you
some examples just to clarify.
So, for example,
let's say that I have a region
that's the entire space with the
origin removed.
OK, so space with the origin
removed, OK, you think it's
simply connected?
Who thinks it's simply
connected?
Who thinks it's not simply
Let's think a little bit harder.
Let's say that I take a loop
like this one,
OK, it doesn't go through the
origin.
Can I find a surface that's
bounded by this loop and that
does not pass through the
origin?
Yeah, I can take the sphere,
you know, for example,
or anything that's just not
quite the disk?
So,
and similarly,
if I take any other loop that
avoids the origin,
I can find, actually,
a surface bounded by it that
does not pass through the
origin.
So, actually,
that's kind of a not so obvious
theorem to prove,
but maybe intuitively,
start by finding any surface.
Well, if that surface passes
through the origin,
just wiggle it a little bit,
you can make sure it doesn't
pass through the origin anymore.
Just push it a little bit.
So, in fact,
this is simply connected.
That was a trick question.
OK, now on the other hand,
a good example of something
that is not simply connected is
if I take space,
and I remove the z axis -- --
that is not simply connected.
And, see, the reason is,
if I look again, say,
at the unit circle in the x
axis,
sorry, unit circle in the xy
plane,
I mean, in the xy plane,
so, if I try to find a surface
whose boundary is this disk,
well, it has to actually cross
the z axis somewhere.
There's no way that I can find
a surface whose only boundary is
this curve, which doesn't hit
the z axis anywhere.
Of course, you could try to use
the same trick as there,
say, maybe we want to go up,
up, up.
You know, let's start with a
cylinder.
Well, the problem is you have
to go infinitely far because the
z axis goes infinitely far.
And, you'll never be able to
actually close your surface.
So, the matter what kind of
trick you might want to use,
it's actually a theorem in
topology that you cannot find a
surface bounded by this disk
without intersecting the z axis.
Yes?
Well, a doughnut shape
certainly would stay away from
the z axis, but it wouldn't be a
surface with boundary just this
guy.
Right, it would have to have
either some other boundary.
So, maybe what you have in mind
is some sort of doughnut shape
like this that curves on itself,
and maybe comes back.
Well, if you don't quite close
it all the way around,
so I can try to,
indeed, draw some sort of
doughnut here.
Well, if I don't quite close
it, that it will have another
edge at the other end wherever I
started.
If I close it completely,
then this curve is no longer
its boundary because my surface
lives on both sides of this
curve.
See, I want a surface that
stops on this curve,
and doesn't go beyond it.
And, nowhere else does it have
that kind of behavior.
Everywhere else,
it keeps going on.
So,
actually, I mean,
maybe actually another way to
convince yourself is to find a
counter example to the statement
I'm going to make about vector
fields with curl zero and simply
connected regions always being
conservative.
So, what you can do is you can
take the example that we had in
one of our older problem sets.
That was a vector field in the
plane.
But, you can also use it to
define a vector field in space
just with no z component.
That vector field is actually
defined everywhere except on the
z axis, and it violates the
usual theorem that we would
expect.
So, that's one way to check
just for sure that this thing is
not simply connected.
So, what's the statement I want
to make?
So, recall we've seen if F is a
gradient field -- -- then its
curl is zero.
That's just the fact that the
mixed second partial derivatives
are equal.
So, now, the converse is the
following theorem.
It says if the curl of F equals
zero in, sorry,
and F is defined -- No,
is not the logical in which to
say it.
So, if F is defined in a simply
connected region,
and curl F is zero -- -- then F
is a gradient field,
and the line integral for F is
path independent -- -- F is
conservative,
and so on,
all the usual consequences.
Remember, these are all
equivalent to each other,
for example,
because you can use path
independence to define the
potential by doing the line
integral of F.
OK, so where do we use the
assumption of being defined in a
simply connected region?
Well, the way which we will
prove this is to use Stokes
theorem.
OK, so the proof,
so just going to prove that the
line integral is path
independent;
the others work the same way.
OK, so let's assume that we
have a vector field whose curl
is zero.
And, let's say that we have two
curves, C1 and C2,
that go from some point P0 to
some point P1,
the same point to the same
point.
Well, we'd like to understand
the line integral along C1,
say, minus the line integral
along C2 to show that this is
zero.
That's what we are trying to
prove.
So, how will we compute that?
Well, the line integral along
C1 minus C2, well,
let's just form a closed curve
that is C1 minus C2.
OK, so let's call C,
woops -- So that's equal to the
integral along C of f dot dr
where C is C1 followed by C2
backwards.
Now, C is a closed curve.
So, I can use Stokes theorem.
Well, to be able to use Stokes
theorem, I need,
actually, to find a surface to
apply it to.
And, that's where the
assumption of simply connected
is useful.
I know in advance that any
closed curve,
so, C in particular,
has to bound some surface.
OK, so we can find S,
a surface, S,
that bounds C because the
region is simply connected.
So, now that tells us we can
actually apply Stokes theorem,
except it won't fit here.
So, instead,
I will do that on the next
line.
That's equal by Stokes to the
double integral over S of curl F
dot vector dS,
or ndS.
But now, the curl is zero.
So, if I integrate zero,
I will get zero.
OK, so I proved that my two
line integrals along C1 and C2
are equal.
But for that,
I needed to be able to find a
surface which to apply Stokes
theorem.
And that required my region to
be simply connected.
If I had a vector field that
was defined only outside of the
z axis and I took two paths that
went on one side and the other
side of the z axis,
I might have obtained,
actually,
different values of the line
integral.
OK, so anyway,
that's the customary warning
about simply connected things.
OK, let me just mention very
quickly that there's a lot of
interesting topology you can do,
actually in space.
So, for example,
this concept of being simply
connected or not,
and studying which loops bound
surfaces or not can be used to
classify shapes of things inside
space.
So, for example,
one of the founding
achievements of topology in the
19th century was to classify
surfaces in space -- -- by
trying to look at loops on them.
So, what I mean by that is that
if I take the surface of a
sphere, well,
I claim the surface of a sphere
-- -- is simply connected.
Why is that?
Well, let's take my favorite
closed curve on the surface of a
sphere.
I can always find a portion of
the sphere that's bounded by it.
OK, so that's the definition of
the surface of a sphere being
simply connected.
On the other hand,
if I take what's called a
torus,
or if you prefer,
the surface of a doughnut,
that's more,
it's a less technical term,
but it's -- -- well,
that's not simply connected.
And, in fact,
for example,
if you look at this loop here
that goes around it,
well, of course it bounds a
surface in space.
But, that surface cannot be
made to be just a piece of the
donut.
You have to go through the hole.
You have to leave the surface
of a torus.
In fact, there's another one.
See, this one also does not
bound anything that's completely
contained in the torus.
And, of course,
it bounds this disc,
but inside of a torus.
But, that's not a part of the
surface itself.
So, in fact,
there's, and topologists would
say, there's two independent --
-- loops that don't bound
surfaces, that don't bound
anything.
And, so this number two is
somehow an invariant that you
can associate to this kind of
shape.
And then, if you consider more
complicated surfaces with more
holes in them,
you can try, somehow,
to count independent loops on
them,
and that's the beginning of the
classification of surfaces.
Anyway, that's not really an
18.02 topic, but I thought I
would mentioned it because it's
kind of a cool idea.
OK, let me say a bit more in
the way of fun remarks like
that.
So, food for thought:
let's say that I want to apply
Stokes theorem to simplify a
line integral along the curve
here.
So, this curve is maybe not
easy to see in the picture.
It kind of goes twice around
the z axis, but spirals up and
then down.
OK, so one way to find a
surface that's bounded by this
curve is to take what's called
the Mobius strip.
OK, so the Mobius strip,
it's a one sided strip where
when you go around,
you flip one side becomes the
other.
So, you just,
if you want to take a band of
paper and glue the two sides
with a twist,
so, it's a one sided surface.
And, that gives us,
actually, serious trouble if we
try to orient it to apply Stokes
theorem.
So, see, for example,
if I take this Mobius strip,
and I try to find an
orientation,
so here it looks like that,
well, let's say that I've
oriented my curve going in this
direction.
So, I go around,
around, around,
still going this direction.
Well, the orientation I should
have for Stokes theorem is that
when I, so, curve continues
here.
Well, if you look at the
convention around here,
it tells us that the normal
vector should be going this way.
OK, if we look at it near here,
if we walk along this way,
the surface is to our right .
So, we should actually be
flipping things upside down.
The normal vector should be
going down.
And, in fact,
if you try to follow your
normal vector that's pointing
up, it's pointing up,
up, up.
It will have to go into things,
into, into, down.
There's no way to choose
consistently a normal vector for
the Mobius strip.
So, that's what we call a
non-orientable surface.
And, that just means it has
only one side.
And, if it has only one side,
that we cannot speak of flux
for it because we have no way of
saying that we'll be counting
things positively one way,
negatively the other way,
because there's only one,
you know,
there's no notion of sides.
So, you can't define a side
towards which things will be
going positively.
So, that's actually a situation
where flux cannot be defined.
OK, so as much as Mobius strips
and climb-bottles are exciting
and really cool,
well, we can't use them in this
class because we can't define
flux through them.
So, if we really wanted to
apply Stokes theorem,
because I've been telling you
that space is simply connected,
and I will always be able to
apply Stokes theorem to any
curve,
what would I do?
Well, I claim this curve
actually bounds another surface
that is orientable.
Yeah, that looks
counterintuitive.
Well, let's see it.
I claim you can take a
hemisphere, and you can take a
small thing and twist it around.
So, in case you don't believe
me, let me do it again with the
transparency.
Here's my loop,
and see, well,
the scale is not exactly the
same.
So, it doesn't quite match.
But, and it's getting a bit
dark.
But, that spherical thing with
a little slit going twisting
into it will actually have
boundary my loop.
And, that one is orientable.
I mean, I leave it up to you to
stare at the picture long enough
to convince yourselves that
there's a well-defined up and
down.
OK.
So now, I mean,
in case you are getting really,
really worried,
I mean, there won't be any
Mobius strips on the exam on
Tuesday, OK?
It's just to show you some cool
stuff.
OK, questions?
No?
OK, one last thing I want to
show you before we start
reviewing,
so one question you might have
about Stokes theorem is,
how come we can choose whatever
surface we want?
I mean, sure,
it seems to work,
but why?
So, I'm going to say a couple
of words about surface
independence in Stokes theorem.
So, let's say that I have a
curve, C, in space.
And, let's say that I want to
apply Stokes theorem.
So, then I can choose my
favorite surface bounded by C.
So, in a situation like this,
for example,
I might want to make my first
choice be this guy,
S1, like maybe some sort of
upper half sphere.
And, if you pay attention to
the orientation conventions,
you'll see that you need to
take it with normal vector
pointing up.
Maybe actually I would rather
make a different choice.
And actually,
I will choose another surface,
S2, that maybe looks like that.
And, if I look carefully at the
orientation convention,
Stokes theorem tells me that I
have to take the normal vector
pointing up again.
So, that's actually into things.
So,
Stokes says that the line
integral along C of my favorite
vector field can be computed
either as a flux integral for
the curl through S1,
or as the same integral,
but through S2 instead of S1.
So, that seems to suggest that
curl F has some sort of surface
independence property.
It doesn't really matter which
surface I take,
as long as the boundary is this
given curve, C.
Why is that?
That's a strange property to
have.
Where does it come from?
Well, let's think about it for
a second.
So, why are these the same?
I mean, of course,
they have to be the same
because that's what Stokes tell
us.
But, why is that OK?
Well, let's think about
comparing the flux integral for
S1 and the flux integral for S2.
So, if we want to compare them,
we should probably subtract
them from each other.
OK, so let's do the flux
integral for S1 minus the flux
integral for S2 of the same
thing.
Well, let's give a name.
Let's call S the surface S1
minus S2.
So, what is S?
S is S1 with its given
orientation together with S2
with the reversed orientation.
So, S is actually this whole
closed surface here.
And, the normal vector to S
seems to be pointing outwards
everywhere.
OK, so now, if we have a closed
surface with a normal vector
pointing outwards,
and we want to find a flux
integral for it,
well,
we can replace that with a
triple integral.
So, that's the divergence
theorem.
So, that's by the divergence
theorem using the fact that S is
a closed surface.
That's equal to the triple
integral over the region inside.
Let me call that region D of
divergence, of curl F dV.
OK, and what I'm going to claim
now is that we can actually
check that if you take the
divergence of the curl of a
vector field,
you always get zero.
OK, and so that will tell you
that this integral will always
be zero.
And that's why the flux for S1,
and the flux for S2 were the
same a priori and we didn't have
to worry about which one we
chose when we did Stokes
theorem.
OK, so let's just check quickly
that divergence of a curve is
zero.
OK, in case you're wondering
why I'm doing all this,
well, first I think it's kind
of interesting,
and second, it reminds you of a
statement of all these theorems,
and all these definitions.
So, in a way,
we are already reviewing.
OK, so let's see.
If my vector field has
components P,
Q, and R, remember that the
curl was defined by this cross
product between del and our
given vector field.
So, that's Ry - Qz followed by
Pz - Rx, and Qx - Py.
So, now, we want to take the
divergence of this.
Well, so we have to take the
first component,
Ry minus Qz,
and take its partial with
respect to x.
Then, take the y component,
Pz minus Rx partial with
respect to y plus Qx minus Py
partial with respect to z.
And, well, now we should expand
this.
But I claim it will always
simplify to zero.
OK, so I think we have over
there, becomes R sub yx minus Q
sub zx plus P sub zy minus R sub
xy plus Q sub xz minus P sub yz.
Well, let's see.
We have P sub zy minus P sub yz.
These two cancel out.
We have R sub yx minus R sub xy.
These cancel out.
Q sub zx and Q sub xz,
these two also cancel out.
So, indeed, the divergence of a
curl is always zero.
OK, so the claim is divergence
of curl is always zero.
Del cross F is always zero,
and just a small remark,
if we had actually real vectors
rather than this strange del
guy,
indeed we know that if we have
two vectors,
U and V,
and we do u dot u cross v,
what is that?
Well, one way to say it is it's
the determinant of u,
u, and v, which is the volume
of the box.
But, it's completely flat
because u, u,
and v are all in the plane
defined by u and v.
The other way to say it is that
u cross v is perpendicular to u
and v.
Well, if it's perpendicular u,
then its dot product with u
will be zero.
So, no matter how you say it,
this is always zero.
So, in a way,
this reinforces our intuition
that del, even though it's not
at all an actual vector
sometimes can be manipulated in
the same way.
OK, I think that's it for new
topics for today.
And,
so, now I should maybe try to
recap quickly what we've learned
in these past three weeks so
that you know,
so, the exam is probably going
to be similar in difficulty to
the practice exams.
That's my goal.
I don't know if I will have
reached that goal or not.
We'll only know that after
you've taken the test.
But, the idea is it's meant to
be more or less the same level
of difficulty.
So, at this point,
we've learned about three kinds
of beasts in space.
OK, so I'm going to divide my
blackboard into three pieces,
and here I will write triple
integrals.
We've learned about double
integrals, and we've learned
about line integrals.
OK, so triple integrals over a
region in space,
we integrate a scalar quantity,
dV.
How do we do that?
Well, we can do that in
rectangular coordinates where dV
becomes something like,
maybe, dz dx dy,
or any permutation of these.
We've seen how to do it also in
cylindrical coordinates where dV
is maybe dz times r dr d theta
or more commonly r dr d theta
dz.
But, what I want to emphasize
in this way is that both of
these you set up pretty much in
the same way.
So, remember,
the main trick here is to find
the bounds of integration.
So, when you do it,
say, with dz first,
that means for fixed xy,
so, for a fixed point in the xy
plane, you have to look at the
bounds for z.
So, that means you have to
figure out what's the bottom
surface of your solid,
and what's the top surface of
your solid?
And, you have to find the value
of z at the bottom,
the value of z at the top as
functions of x and y.
And then, you will put that as
bounds for z.
Once you've done that,
you are left with the question
of finding bounds for x and y.
Well, for that,
you just rotate the picture,
look at your solid from above,
so, look at its projection to
the xy plane,
and you set up a double
integral either in rectangular
xy coordinates,
or in polar coordinates for x
and y.
Of course, you can always do it
a different orders.
And, I'll let you figure out
again how that goes.
But, if you do dz first,
then the inner bounds are given
by bottom and top,
and the outer ones are given by
looking at the shadow of the
region.
Now, there's also spherical
coordinates.
And there, we've seen that dV
is rho squared sine phi d rho d
phi d theta.
So now, of course,
if this orgy of Greek letters
is confusing you at this point,
then you probably need to first
review spherical coordinates for
themselves.
Remember that rho is the
distance from the origin.
Phi is the angle down from the
z axis.
So, it's zero,
and the positive z axis,
pi over two in the xy plane,
and increases all the way to pi
on the negative z axis.
And, theta is the angle around
the z axis.
So, now, when we set up bounds
here,
it will look a lot like what
you've done in polar coordinates
in the plane because when you
look at the inner bound down on
rho,
for a fixed phi and theta,
that means you're shooting a
straight ray from the origin in
some direction in space.
So, you know,
you're sending a laser beam,
and you want to know what part
of your beam is going to be in
your given solid.
You want to solve for the value
of rho when you enter the solid
and when you leave it.
I mean, very often,
if the origin is in your solid,
then rho will start at zero.
Then you want to know when you
exit.
And, I mean,
there's a fairly small list of
kinds of surfaces that we've
seen how to set up in spherical
coordinates.
So, if you're really upset by
this, go over the problems in
the notes.
That will give you a good idea
of what kinds of things we've
seen in spherical coordinates.
OK, and then evaluation is the
usual way.
Questions about this?
No?
OK, so, I should say we can do
something bad,
but so we've seen,
of course, applications of
this.
So, we should know how to use a
triple integral to evaluate
things like a mass of a solid,
the average value of a
function,
the moment of inertia about one
of the coordinate axes,
or the gravitational attraction
on a mass at the origin.
OK, so these are just formulas
to remember for examples of
triple integrals.
It doesn't change conceptually.
You always set them up and
evaluate them the same way.
It just tells you what to put
there for the integrand.
Now,
double integrals: so,
when we have a surface in
space,
well, what we will integrate on
it,
at least what we've seen how to
integrate is a vector field
dotted with the unit normal
vector times the area element.
OK, and this is sometimes
called vector dS.
Now, how do we evaluate that?
Well, we've seen formulas for
ndS in various settings.
And, once you have a formula
for ndS, that will relate ndS to
maybe dx dy, or something else.
And then, you will express,
so, for example,
ndS equals something dx dy.
And then, it becomes a double
integral of something dx dy.
Now, in the integrand,
you want to express everything
in terms of x and y.
So, if you had a z,
maybe you have a formula for z
in terms of x and y.
And, when you set up the
bounds, well,
you try to figure out what are
the bounds for x and y?
That would be just looking at
it from above.
Of course, if you are using
other variables,
figure out the bounds for those
variables.
And, when you've done that,
it becomes just a double
integral in the usual sense.
OK, so maybe I should be a bit
more explicit about formulas
because there have been a lot.
So, let me tell you about a few
of them.
Let me actually do that over
here because I don't want to
make this too crowded.
OK, so what kinds of formulas
for ndS have we seen?
Well, we've seen a formula,
for example,
for a horizontal plane,
or for something that's
parallel to the yz plane or the
xz plane.
Well, let's do just the yz
plane for a quick reminder.
So, if I have a surface that's
contained inside the yz plane,
then obviously I will express
ds in terms of,
well, I will use y and z as my
variables.
So, I will say that ds is dy
dz, or dz dy,
whatever's most convenient.
Maybe we will even switch to
polar coordinates after that if
a problem wants us to.
And, what about the normal
vector?
Well, the normal vector is
either coming straight at us,
or it's maybe going back away
from us depending on which
orientation we've chosen.
So, this gives us ndS.
We dot our favorite vector
field with it.
We integrate,
and we get the answer.
OK, we've seen about spheres
and cylinders centered at the
origin or centered on the z
axis.
So, the normal vector sticks
straight out or straight in,
depending on which direction
you do it in.
So, for a sphere,
the normal vector is <x,
y, z> divided by the radius
of the sphere.
For a cylinder,
it's <x, y,
0>, divided by the radius of
a cylinder.
And, the surface element on a
sphere,
so, see, it's very closely
related to the volume element of
spherical coordinates except you
don't have a rho anymore.
You just plug in a rho equals a.
So, you get a squared sine phi
d phi d theta.
And, for a cylinder,
it would be a dz d theta.
So,
by the way, just a quick check,
when you're doing an integral,
if it's the surface integral,
there should be two integral
signs,
and there should be two
integration variables.
And, there should be two d
somethings.
If you end up with a dx,
dy, dz in the surface integral,
something is seriously wrong.
OK, now, besides these specific
formulas, we've seen two general
formulas that are also useful.
So, one is,
if we know how to express z in
terms of x and y,
and just to change notation to
show you that it's not set in
stone,
let's say that z is known as a
function z of x and y.
So, how do I get ndS in that
case?
Well, we've seen a formula that
says negative partial z partial
x, negative partial z partial y,
one dx dy.
So, this formula relates the
volume, sorry,
the surface element on our
surface to the area element in
the xy plane.
It lets us convert between dS
and dx dy.
OK, so we just plug in this,
and we dot with F,
and then we substitute
everything in terms of x and y,
and we evaluate the integral
over x and y.
If we don't really want to find
a way to find z as a function of
x and y,
but we have a normal vector
given to us,
then we have another formula
which says that ndS is,
sorry, I should have said it's
always up to sign because we
have a two orientation
convention.
We have to decide based on what
we are trying to do,
whether we are doing the
correct convention or the wrong
one.
So, the other formula is n over
n dot k dx dy.
Sorry, are they all the same?
Well, if you want,
you can put an absolute value
here.
But, it doesn't matter because
it's up to sign anyway.
So, I mean, this formula is
valid as it is.
OK, and, I mean,
if you're in a situation where
you can apply more than one
formula,
they will all give you the same
answer in the end because it's
the same flux integral.
OK, so anyway,
so we have various ways of
computing surface integrals,
and probably one of the best
possible things you can do to
prepare for the test is actually
to look again at some practice
problems from the notes that do
flux integrals over various
kinds of surfaces because that's
probably one of the hardest
topics in this unit of the
class.
OK, anyway, let's move on to
line integrals.
So, those are actually a piece
of cake in comparison,
OK, because all that this is,
is just integral of P dx Q dy R
dz.
And, then all you have to do is
parameterize the curve,
C, to express everything in
terms of a single variable.
And then, you end up with a
usual single integral,
and you can just compute it.
So, that one works pretty much
as it did in the plane.
So, if you forgotten what we
did in the plane,
it's really the same thing.
OK, so now we have three
different kinds of integrals,
and really, well,
they certainly have in common
that they integrate things
somehow.
But, apart from that,
they are extremely different in
what they do.
I mean, this one involves a
function, a scalar quantity.
These involve vector quantities.
They don't involve the same
kinds of shapes over which to
integrate.
Here, you integrate over a
three-dimensional region.
Here, you integrate only over a
two-dimensional surface,
and here, only a
one-dimensional curve.
So, try not to confuse them.
That's basically the most
important advice.
Don't get mistaken.
Each of them has a different
way of getting evaluated.
Eventually, they will all give
you numbers, but through
different processes.
So now, well,
I said these guys are
completely different.
Well, they are,
but we still have some bridges
between them.
OK, so we have two,
maybe I should say three,
well, two bridges between these
guys.
OK, so we have somehow a
connection between these which
is the divergence theorem.
We have a connection between
that, which is Stokes theorem.
So -- Just to write them again,
so the divergence theorem says
if I have a region in space,
and I call its boundary S,
so, it's going to be a closed
surface,
and I orient S with a normal
vector pointing outwards,
then whenever I have a surface
integral over S,
sorry,
I can replace it by a triple
integral over the region inside.
OK, so this guy is a vector
field.
And, this guy is a function
that somehow relates to the
vector field.
I mean, you should know how.
You should know the definition
of divergence,
of course.
But, what I want to point out
is if you have to compute the
two sides separately,
well, this is just,
you know, your standard flux
integral.
This is just your standard
triple integral over a region in
space.
Once you have computed what
this guy is, it's really just a
triple integral of the function.
So, the way in which you
compute it doesn't see that it
came from a divergence.
It's just the same way that you
would compute any other triple
integral.
The way we compute it doesn't
depend on what actually we are
integrating.
Stokes theorem says if I have a
curve that's the boundary of a
surface, S,
and I orient the two in
compatible manners,
then I can replace a line
integral on C by a surface
integral on S.
OK, and that surface integral,
well, it's not for the same
vector field.
This relates a line integral
for one field to a surface
integral from another field.
That other field is given from
the first one just by taking its
curl So, after you take the
curl, you obtain a different
vector field.
And, the way in which you would
compute the surface integral is
just as with any surface
integral.
You just find a formula for ndS
dot product, substitute,
evaluate.
The calculation of this thing,
once you've computed curl does
not remember that it was a curl.
It's the same as with any other
flux integral.
OK, and finally,
the last bridge,
so this was between two and
three.
This was between one and two.
Let me just say,
there's a bridge between zero
and one,
which is that if you have a
function in its gradient,
well, the fundamental theorem
of calculus says that the line
integral for the vector field
given by the gradient of a
function is actually equal to
the change in value of a
function.
That's if you have a curve
bounded by P0 and P1.
So in a way, actually,
each of these three theorems
relates a quantity with a
certain number of integral signs
to a quantity with one more
integral sign.
And, that's actually somehow a
fundamental similarity between
them.
But maybe it's easier to think
of them as completely different
stories.
So now, with this one,
we additionally have to
remember another topic is given
a vector field,
F, with curl equal to zero,
find the potential.
And, we've seen two methods for
that, and I'm sure you remember
them.
So, if not, then try to
remember them for Tuesday.
OK, so anyway,
again, conceptually,
we have, really,
three different kinds of
integrals.
We evaluated them in completely
different ways,
and we have a handful of
theorems, connecting them to
each other.
But, that doesn't have any
impact on how we actually
compute things.